rennes le 29 janvier dernier mise à sac
des locaux de l'association universel
pour le christianisme mondial depuis
plusieurs semaines pétition et campagne
de signatures demandent l'interdiction
de l'église de sun myung moon un
attentat à la bombe dans un local
parisien de l'association a déjà fait
deux victimes les incidents se
multiplient et projette sous l'éclairage
de l'actualité quelques 500 jeunes
français disciple de moules
l'opinion publique et accuse de répandre
une drogue de l'âme les principes divins
de monsieur mouthe
2 mars les dossiers de l'écran
madame champollion professeur de
linguistique à l'université de rennes
suit l'émission
en octobre 1974 son fils yves a tout
quitté famille et études pour devenir
ministre
le docteur champollion avait alors créé
l'association de défense de la famille
et de l'individu
[Musique]
est ce que vous auriez accepté par
exemple qu'il veuille devenir prêtre
j'aurais certainement accepté comme j'ai
d'ailleurs accepté bien autre chose mais
bien sûr ils n'auraient certainement
mûrement réfléchi il y aura été aidé par
beaucoup d'autres ça ne se passe pas
comme ça c'est l'illusion d'une solution
c'est à dire que c'est ce qu'on nous dit
d'ailleurs dit certains jeunes j'avais
des problèmes je n'en ai plus c'est tout
à fait typique c'est ne vous plus
vouloir avoir de problème or vivre c'est
vraiment affronter des problèmes et non
pas fuir soit en avant soit en arrière
j'ai une bonne famille mes parents sont
très bien mes frères et soeurs aussi
j'avais pas trouvé l'amour dont j'avais
besoin dans cette famille au lycée je
n'arrivais pas à trouver les réponses
aux questions que je voulais se
connaître ce que c'était que la vie et
l'amour en fait et la liberté mais trois
grandes questions alors je suis parti
j'ai cherché très vite j'étais dans le
milieu et puis j'ai pris par la drogue
vraiment pressée c'est quelque chose
d'abominable on cherche on cherche les
facois ce qu'on cherche et on n'arrive
pas à trouver l'idéal qu'on recherche à
chaque fois on en prend et on accumule
type lit les doses en fait on ne peut
pas satisfait pas parce que plus de
désintoxiquer facilement d'un seul coup
pratiquement quand j'ai rencontré dieu
c'était fini et dure entre guy avec moon
oui
les libertés ou les prisons de dieu les
caméras de vendredi sont allés regarder
vivre les adeptes des sectes religieuses
dont l'actualité parle beaucoup alors il
vous gummo moi j'ai une question à vous
poser qu'est ce que vous avez voulu
montrer très difficile à dire
la mesure où on avait à juger d'un d'un
phénomène irrationnel se veut à la fois
des autres est-ce qu'on peut juger
d'abord de la foi des autres je pense
pas on peut simplement essayé de d'être
là comme un révélateur d'essayer de
faire émerger cette fois alors ça donne
quoi je voudrais quelque chose de très
direct et au fond là vous êtes mariés
vous et des enfants marié sans enfant
vous auriez des enfants chez moune voilà
seriez effrayer ou pas
liberté ou prison chez moune
oui une réponse tout de suite
notre sentiment vous avez tourné pendant
un mois vous avez regardé les sectes
tout que c'est une question que je me
pose encore
est ce que les gens ne font pas
eux-mêmes leur prison c'est tout le
problème
je crois que beaucoup d'entre nous ont
besoin de structures très rigide pour se
sécuriser pour ne pas avoir à faire face
aux agressions du monde extérieur dans
sa jolie confrontés c'est le débat et
c'est votre fils mais en vain regarde de
15 ans à 20 ans je voulais être
missionnaire et de 21 à 25 ans j'avais
complètement perdu la foi l'église
catholique on m'avait vraiment dégoûté
et j'ai commencé à étudier plein de
groupes plein de religion et je
cherchais vraiment des gens qui
pouvaient vivre en communauté et comme
c'était écrit dans la bible et un jour
j'ai vraiment prier dieu désespérément
qu'il me montre son plan c'était une
première fois et le lendemain j'ai
rencontré un membre des enfants de dieu
et là j'ai tout de suite su à la famille
et pendant ces deux années j'ai vraiment
j'ai vraiment vécu la foi la foi
profonde et des chrétiens et la joie et
le partage aussi l'amour aussi j'ai
appris beaucoup chez les enfants de dieu
et tu vas j'avais envie de fonder un
couple scié mais les leaders n'étaient
en contradiction pour que j'épouse ce
frère et certains voulaient d'autres
voulaient pas alors c'était toujours en
période c'était toujours instable oui la
liberté
de ton histoire
la liberté pour moi la liberté c'est de
pouvoir servir dieu finalement j'ai
quitté j'étais accusé de beaucoup de
choses mais c'était pas juste et
certaines choses comme d'être possédé du
démon parce que j'étais pas toujours
d'accord avec ce qui était déclarée ou
bien d'avoir au sort scellé une jeune
fille des choses comme ça et on te passe
en jugement oui ça je suis passé devant
le conseil et après à moi où j'étais
sorti de la famille c'est la
condamnation a exclu de famille pas
vraiment parce que on voulait me faire
rentrer de nouveaux j'attends d'elle la
décision alors il sait que dans la rue
tout seul oui c'est à dire qu'on m'a dit
débrouille toi et dans deux semaines tu
reprendras contact avec nous tu peux
laisser des gens tu avais de l'argent
comprenez vous que déjà nos comme vous
se laisse prendre dans un groupe de ces
gens là et que cherchaient-ils d'après
vous qu'attendent ils
je pense que que s'ils partent c'est que
ne sont pas très satisfaits pour
l'endroit où ils vivent
mais je pense que la société qu'on
élevés ont souvent offre beaucoup de
désillusion pour les gens qui vivent
elles c'est dur c'est ce mandat c'est
inhumain et puis on n'a pas l'impression
d'être aimée dans une grande ville on
est tout seul dans la rubrique on sent
entouré en fait ça ces clichés et puis
moi je moi je pense que si on parle
assez ce serait pour rencontrer une
certaine fraternité pour pour rencontrer
d'autres personnes des gens qui ont
l'air de vous aimer de s'intéresser à
vous
[Musique]
dc
allez y
[Musique]
on nous nous sommes ici pour
l'observateur extérieur nous sommes bien
engagés dans le système nous allons
devenir les ingénieurs nous allons
contribuer à le faire à le faire marcher
comme il est alors c'est facile
finalement de dire bien il est très bien
il faut rester à l'intérieur pour lutter
mais moi mon avis effectivement sortir
ça peut sembler une fuite mais rester à
l'intérieur j'ai pas du tout
l'impression qu'on arrivera à le changer
on présente la société avec sa pollution
avec la l'éventualité d'une guerre
atomique ou quoi que ce soit alors que
font ces jeunes qui s'engagent ou plutôt
ceux qui les font s'engager dans les
sacs on leur dit la société elle est
pourrie venez donc dans la dans la secte
des enfants de dieu là on sera seul
sauveur 1992 c'est la fin du monde nous
on s'en sortira tous les autres oeuvres
ont ça c'est du courage c'est et c'est
l'amour des hommes
[Musique]
2 5 m
il veut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sans laisser de traces
je n'avais pas d'argent je connaissais
par ça comment as tu vécu par la fois je
savais que dieu m'aiderait qu'il me
donnerait toutes les choses dont j'aurai
besoin il fallait seulement voir la fois
et j'ai rencontré une personne qui m'a
donné une chambre 7e étage et après un
mois de cette période de transition j'ai
réalisé que je pouvais seulement être
missionnaire et travailler pour jésus et
que c'était toute ma vie alors j'ai
vraiment prier dieu ce jour là qui me
montrait son plan et le jour même j'ai
rencontré une jeune fille qui m'a évité
rue madame et je lui dis de quelle
association et tuer je ne sais pas
pourquoi mais je savais tout de suite
qu'elle était de la secte moon et met sa
gentillesse et sa joie m'ont vraiment
convaincu d'aller de ne pas de ne pas
avoir peur tu m'as vraiment parlé il m'a
montré que que monsieur moon était était
vraiment le messie du second événement
sun myung moon sud coréen né en 1920
dans une famille protestante à 16 ans un
matin de pâques le christ lui serait
apparue pour lui demander d'accomplir la
mission qu'il n'avait pu mener à bien
1954 il fonde à séoul l'église de
l'unification
un credo sont libres les principes
divins livre dans lequel il annonce la
venue prochaine d'un messie en corée et
prône l'unification des différentes
religions
aujourd'hui derrière lui deux millions
de disciples dans une centaine de pays
leurs biens sont au service de la
communauté ministres dont les règles de
vie interdisent les cigarettes l'alcool
les drogues et les relations sexuelles
hors mariage
l'indépendance de l'église est assurée
par l' empire industriel de monsieur
moon une liste interminable de société
deux magasins d'usiné de journaux une
véritable multinationale aux activités
très diversifiées au bout un chiffre
d'affaires d'environ 60 millions de
dollars qui proviennent aussi bien de la
fabrication de carabine à air comprimé
que de la vente du t2 de ginseng ou de
l'extraction du design des informations
qui ont suscité la curiosité des
ingénieurs conseils de 33 ans père de
deux enfants si michel mouillot plutôt
sur le en ce qui me concerne je
reconnais à chacun droit de penser ce
qu'il veut jérôme a donné un tract dans
la rue j'étais intéressé je suis venu
voir si on veut voir ce que c'était
maintenant il ya des choses que j'ai
vues qui sont totalement con
contradiction avec ce qu'a pu dire une
certaine presse c'est évident ce
absolument pas ça du tout
là j'étais un peu surpris a failli à
vienne vraiment un état de subjectivité
qui est totale quoi bon les gens qui
sont ici sont majeurs
ils sont libres de partir quand ils le
veulent
la preuve c'est lui avec un appareil
photo personne ne m'en a empêché je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse dire que ce soit
des gens qui font des lavages de cerveau
ça me parait débile de plus il n'y a pas
de drogue il n'y a pas ce n'est pas un
lupanar il n'y a pas de
absolument rien quoi qui corresponde à
ce
jour là excusez moi je fais partie d'un
groupe déjà chrétiens
j'en ai marre bonjour j'ai mois avec un
taux de femmes et de nouvel espoir
et vous voulez avez la possibilité de
venir les nôtres simple
l'étape à 2 minutes j'en ai je suis
intéressé pour une part une chose
monsieur le retour à l'église primitive
comme au temps des premiers chrétiens
l'église vrai l'église authentiques tels
que tel que le christ a laissé son dépôt
à ses apôtres
money à quelques kilomètres de rouen le
dimanche il y a fool aux grilles du
château c'est l'un des centres de
l'église de monsieur me le séminaire
d'étude des principes divins trois sets
21 jours s'y succèdent sans interruption
alors si l'on pouvait apercevoir l'un de
ces fameux mills une manière comme une
autre de l'agrémenter la sortie
dominicale et on n'est pas déçu parce
que chez moune on recherche le contact
ça vous plairait de venir tenter une
expérience avec nous on vit quand par
exemple les services de outre un jour
pour découvrir ce que nous ressentons
vraiment non pas spécialement parce que
j'estime que pour vous c'est peut-être
pas ridicule pour moi personnellement
voyant sache que c'est carrément
ridicule parce que à mon avis ou perdez
votre temps quoi vous pensez quand même
on ne demande pas à venir vivre ici pas
la même de loin on peut demander à
quelqu'un d'être à venir des travaux ne
sera pas dire de ainsi dire quelque
chose d aussi de rien du tout c'est les
pneus fraternité surtout demain
autant puisque nous sommes des pionniers
jamais perdu son temps mais non mon bas
écoutez j'ai pas mon match si par
exemple je crois en quelque chose
quelque chose que je peux croire bon bah
c'est en dur aussi croyez vous en dieu
mais non puisque jeu en réalité si tout
le monde sait mais vraiment comme un
adieu moi j'aurais pu dire qu'une
religion diana 36 alors qu'est-ce qu'il
faut aimer
[Musique]
à son âge était en troisième c'est une
normale quoi encore secondaire les
arrêter oui c'est ne t'inquiète pas ça
pas du tout mais si un jour tu changé
c'est affreux n'était plus la même durée
des difficultés très serrée dans la vie
oui peut-être mais je crois je veux
continuer dans ma foi énormément
ça nous a pas posé de problèmes aux
dames ces jeux de automatiquement quand
on découvre un mouvement on voudrait
connaître tout de suite la vérité mais
c'est comme la vie c'est une découverte
et à mesure alors pour moi ce que très
très important sur cette terre puisque
je suis chrétienne c'est donc en
priorité de se construire d'avoir les
valeurs intérieures d'être très solide
pour moi c'est bien plus important qu'un
bachelot parce que l'âne êtres humains
kg et qui est solide intérieurement pour
a tout assumé plus tard beaucoup plus
qu'un simple qu'un simple bachelot alors
moi je me dis c'est peut-être pas lui
j'ai toujours rêvé d'avoir un fils près
de sainte cécile alors au début ma
première réaction je lis mon dieu à
mouvement tellement bien une telle
pureté mais pourquoi ce qui sort pas de
mon église catholique que j'ai ce j'aime
et que je respecte dans la vie vous moi
je dirige une école de danse classique
depuis 30 ans ce qui fait que je connais
beaucoup de jeunes et ça bien qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses qui va pas dans notre
monde qu'il faut que ça change ça c'est
sûr que ça va changer avec nous et
j'espère je crois que tous les
journalistes qui a une conscience
professionnelle profonde devrait
vraiment s'attacher de savoir où ils ont
pris les sources quelles sont celles qui
sont qui peuvent être vraies excellent
qui souffre veut dire que commis depuis
l'âge de 16 ans il mange avec les wings
il serait mort il serait mort déjà s'il
y avait des bouts de bois s'il y avait
plein de la drogue ou si on le laissait
pas l'épaule il serait mort déjà christa
non je dire que je les sens vraiment
totalement libre
faites vous des jeunes qui viennent ici
des hommes et des femmes libres et ça
c'est bien sûr ça seulement livres
vêtements par exemple la campagne qui
est écoutée de votre femme vous l'avez
choisie vous même
c'est une
simple démo choix personnel mais je
librement accepté ça profondément j'ai
vu que à travers cette expérience
de mes frères et soeurs plus âgés et de
monsieur moon j'ai remarqué que je
pouvais être confié mon coeur et ma vie
dans leurs mains et la preuve est là que
je suis beaucoup plus heureux d'avoir
reçu cette femme que d'avoir choisi ma
femme
la
forme osé me gêne on autoriser et
braquant lèvres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui sont un peu la société dans wells
dans 1984 quand même nom
aux étés où tout est dirigé où l'homme
n'a plus de livres arbitres ou tout est
prévu pour lui
non il s'agit dans cette famille de re
découvrir dieu et ainsi de vraiment être
ce mettre confiant à travers des
personnes qui sont plus proches de dieu
sait ce que je pense oui mais ce lien
peut être brisé un jour par exemple
ces jeunes que vous arrêter dans leur
étude
ce n'est pas leur donner une possibilité
d'élargir leur choix plus tard si
d'aventuré vous le quittez la famille
en réalité nous ne forçons aucune
personne arrêté leurs études ou et 80%
des jeunes qui sont chez vous arrêtent
leurs études cela c'est leur décision
personnelle
c'est sans doute vrai et puis à quoi bon
les études là tout est beaucoup plus
simple dans l'enseignement des principes
divins du révérend moon en trois jours
on acquiert des certitudes on retrouve
les paradis perdus de l'irrationnel
donc je me souvins faire c'est commencer
à avoir un premier temps bible comment
dieu à faire en sorte qu'elles gif ce
après un jour et ce même s'ils viennent
qu'ensuite que les chrétiens il ya nous
sommes prêts à ce qu'un joueur aussi
d'une missive yens quelques c'est écrit
dans les textes en premier on peut
écrire que attend ici est apparu
il avait dit que 4000 ans entre la
demande et christ et que 2 adam à une
personne que tout le monde a connue
autrefois il ya 800 ans
adam
no
line on quand on ne vit que adam a
existé 4000 en jésus-christ ça ne te
donne pas
ça peut étonner mais je pense que c'est
une réalité auquel il a vraiment existé
peut-être une en or jésus christ tu
crois bon quand il y enseigne ici que
dans aînés 4000 ans avant jésus-christ
qui fera peut-être un jour aller
défendre la corée du sud contre la corée
du nord que le communisme c'est satan
etc etc tu crois réellement à tout ce
que tu enseignes et tu penses que les
gens qui sont ici sont suffisamment armé
pour avoir leur libre arbitre pour
pouvoir discuter certains voient en
premier j'ai une pensée nier ce que vous
avez dit c'est à dire que on irait se
battre contre la corée du nord une page
s'est pas du tout prêt à porter une arme
contre quiconque reçoit un communiste ou
non et c'est quelque chose que l'on
enseigne ici qu'on doit aller partir en
corée un jour se battre quand on se dit
qu'il faudra peut-être un jour aller en
corée pour aider la corée du sud à faire
face à une agression de la corée du nord
je ne
savais pas
ça dépend si dieu me l'a dit c'est aussi
dieu veut qu'on vaut mieux là bas pour
défendre la corée et nous lira le 300 et
comment lire hâtive
ça je peux pas vous répondre là dessus
mais toi tu partirais si je me dis je
partirai
bon j'ai ici des fiches que tu as fait
sur tes élèves lors sur le premier je
lis bonne personne très touché par le
problème du communisme accepte et
comprend les principes mais attention
peut être malade entre parenthèses
tuberculose peut revenir si les séparer
de l'âne j'ai également la fille ce que
tu as fait sur l'âne malade physiquement
cause
spirituel certainement va
réalise très peu les principes inutile
de recontacter je donne cette fiche est
un très simple sont nés des personnes
survenu pour trois jours ici et là le
premier intéressé par l'épreuve du
communisme possession c'était une
personne qui a eu à se battre contre
ces gens sous les huées en vue des
grands la victoire que tu ne fallait pas
du tout le communisme dont je parlais du
coup du comice même pas dame de fer la
manière dont vous le dites il est comme
une armée du diable
monsieur moon le côté de satan est satan
et le monde communiste se trouve normal
de france et des gens se séparer non non
mais dis eh bien si c'est son ensemble
souffre à son ami vila maire claude je
crois franchement je ne suis pas sûr
donc c'est impossible qu'ils n'aient pas
kevin ici non qui se trouve non tu te
trompes c'est celui qui était prêt à
venir chez vous qu'il fallait contacter
qu'avait la tuberculose celui qui
voulait pas bien chez vous et est très
sain d'esprit dr si on se construit
ainsi peut-être gmi
celui que la tuberculose oui mercedes
après qu'ils aient pas qu'il n'ya pas à
rennes mais l'autre la rue ici c'est
bien compliqué de gérer mais c'est
simple si vous voulez dire ça oui voir à
rennes ces personnes là moi je connais
très bien
tu sais compte afficher comme ça
mal
non je ne sais pas tu d'accord avec ce
genre de choses
et ici tu te sens bien très bien c'est
vraiment la vie de famille entre frères
et soeurs et ce n'est pas trop dur parce
que finalement les conférences sont
longues on dort pas beaucoup
dur non non rien est difficile on est
mieux qu'à paris ou ailleurs je crois
que une vie comme ici on en trouve
partout
[Musique]
non
eolas unis
et au canada
trente trois élèves suivent ce séminaire
de 21 jours 26 garçons cette fille
moyenne d'âge 23 ans un tiers
d'étrangers
sept d'entre eux sont étudiants huit
employés de bureau et 900 emplois va
commencer ce soir là cette critique
critique et contre propositions du
marxisme donc ce soir par le
matérialisme mataly ce mondial alors
d'abord qu'est ce que c'est que la
matière selon mars eh bien disons que la
matière car attisée par trois trois
aspects
la matière
c'est une substance objective qui
existent indépendamment de la conscience
de l'homme et qui a le mouvement en
elle-même profession des parents
agriculteurs quatre commerçants et
artisans
quatre employés cinq cadres et
professions libérales huit ouvriers neuf
substances objectif indépendante de la
conscience humaine et qui a le mouvement
en elle-même voilà ce qui va être
définir la matière selon mars seuls 10
d'entre eux ont affirmé savoir au début
du cours
ce qu'était le marxisme
au contraire les principes du bar on
nous montrait que si cet univers est un
univers d'ordre de loi d'harmonie et
bien en effet la source
et les neiges et cette
contre-proposition des princes divin et
que la sauce de l'univers en fait c'est
un être unique qui est à la fois
esprits et matières nous appelons vieux
monsieur moon nous n'ayons l'ordre
existant le monde existant les nations
existantes la société existante les
familles existantes les parents
existants les frères existants vous
faites de l'anticommunisme une religion
pratiquement non
c'est un opinion personnelle est
effectivement c'est le pignon de
monsieur mono ci et ses opinions de tous
les adeptes de votre mouvement bien sûr
à mon point de vue nous ne pouvons pas
être chrétien et marxiste parce que à
marxiste ni dieu un chrétien vie pour
dire selon vous la dernière mesure de
dieu sur terre sera une troisième guerre
mondiale dans laquelle bien sûr le
communisme sera complètement assujettis
en réalité cette troisième guerre
mondiale semble inévitable hélas pour
cause le communisme mondial je veux
faire ce point le communisme et non pas
les communistes le communisme c'est à
dire le marxisme est basée sur des
principes que l'on peut voir avec
réflexion qui sont faux nous pouvons pas
accepter une chose fausse niveau nîmois
sont des a priori qui sont les vôtres
tiens c'est pour ça nous invitons chaque
personne a étudié à contrôler ce que
nous avons ici dans nos mains
parce que vous dites cela vous n'êtes
pas sous hypnose spirituel chinois pas
réellement exister encore monsieur moon
oui bien sûr il existe une sorte
d'hypnose spirituelle qui est une
fonction de la puissance spirituelle si
vous êtes sur le point de tuer il faut
vraiment le faire ou si vous allez
frapper quelque chose il faut vraiment
le frapper
vous devez faire les choses avec la même
concentration et cela marchera ou que ce
texte non je ne connais pas ce texte
vous connaissez le litex muscle
conférence de monsieur moon à los
angeles bien
et quelle est la question sur quoi sur
quels points dois je répondre je vous
demande si vous voulez pas vous même
sous hypnose
il est certain que à travers cette
doctrine que monsieur moon donne mon
coeur et ma pensée sont dirigés vers ce
don de soi que je n'avais pas du tout
avant ou bien si vous appelez ça une hip
hop d'être totalement concentré faire le
dos rond et même
jusqu'à mourir pour mes propres frères
et soeurs ça je veux le faire dans la
mesure où je sais je peux sauver leur
vie monsieur moon la tradition doit être
établi sur la détermination absolue au
sacrifice c'est un peu un langage de
phénotype non nous expliquer tout part
cela votre foi oui parce que tu te
retrouves n'est tout revient à cela
c'est que ma propre vie a trouvé ce
déclic que je cherchais depuis depuis
l'âge depuis l'enfance
j'en ai besoin j'en ai envie
c'est une question de survie
oui je suis passé par ici
[Musique]